well today is international migrants day
it's marked by the UN to highlight the
contributions migrants make and the
problems that they face it's of taking
place of course in the middle of a
brutally cold winter here in Europe but
plunging temperatures have not put off
migrants trying to cross into the EU one
increasingly popular point of entry is
along the border between Serbia which is
not in the EU and Hungary which is
around the Serbian Village of horogosh
where there's a border crossing a number
of illegal migrant camps have emerged
our report to Idris zafiri visited one
of them recently
say for the mirzada volunteers with the
group helping migrants on their way west
he understands more than most what we
are driving towards he came here from
Afghanistan and knows what it is to risk
everything for a chance of something
better
when you are on this road you don't know
what's going to happen in an hour what
will happen to you
you're walking in a jungle with
Smugglers but you will never know if you
will make it or not or where you are
going to
was 14 when he tried to get to Germany
he only made it to Serbia now he helps
those determined to get further the
volunteers go out a few times a week
towards the border with Hungary with the
EU
there they find camps like this one
abandoned buildings a few kilometers
from the border talat has made it all
this way from Pakistan
it is hard to cross the border because
of the Hungarian police I've spent a
month here and I've tried eight or nine
times to get across but we didn't make
it yet there are too many Patrols
now I'm waiting for a friend who broke
his leg to get better and we will try
again
he is one of the few to add some kind of
solid shelter his focus is on the long
process by which he hopes to get
protection for his family
I have four children in Pakistan and my
plan is to make it to Germany as soon as
possible
I hope I can get Asylum and later I can
take my children to Germany
you can find camps like this dotted
around the Border region this one is
largely Afghans enduring medieval
conditions for their dreams of the
future
activists and refugees eat together the
sense of solidarity as important as the
supplies they bring
well more than a million ukrainians have
settled here in Germany since the start
of the war a new study shows many of
them are integrating well and quickly
our reporter Emily gaudine met with the
young family who came here in March
a life and safety that's what Dima and
Christina wanted for their daughter
Donna
they fled Ukraine within hours of the
war starting back in February
Christina was pregnant at the time
they made a split second decision
I was not ready to move to another
country it's really surprise for me so
um I I I I I can't imagine that my baby
was born in Ukraine but I cannot imagine
that my baby were born in another
country but the Russian invasion changed
everything their home was in the firing
line
while the couple had friends in Berlin
Germany was still a foreign land
they faced the hurdles of bureaucracy
and had to get used to the peculiarities
of German life
and I thought okay maybe Brooks is
something like regular maybe we had the
same in Ukraine but it's a bit different
because like you need to have like
termins and it takes a long time to to
yeah all this paperwork
post mail in through the post it's
really a surprise us because in Ukraine
we don't have all of this
Dima and Christina both found jobs quite
quickly in Berlin Dima is a designer and
art director Christina Works in
advertising but she's also a musician
she even performed here in Germany while
pregnant
[Music]
yeah lots of good moments also like as I
said like giving birth here and medicine
and like Berlin is amazing City to just
give a walk like lots of parks and yeah
lots of children yeah yeah so it's
Inspire us every day yeah and lots of
working possibilities I found to work
quite easily like lots of propositions
and yeah we're quite happy with it
not all of the 1 million refugees coming
from Ukraine have been this fortunate
Dima and Christina have settled into
their new life in Berlin and while
they're Keen to return to Ukraine
they're determined to make the best of
it until the war is over